you want to knit while we talk crochet
crochet while we talk yes okay
cool I like that it's
a one of the
tools that I
use sometimes to talk about the things
that I've experienced in life you
understand we all need
tools to
manage all right
Mary Mary where were you born where you
from originally I was born in
Pennsylvania to an Amish family I was
the sixth child and the only girl at
that point in time
my parents had um three more Sons After
me when I was
uh
five my seven-year-old cousin my uncle
and my biological father were all killed
in a tragic car buggy
accident my biological mother got
remarried when I was 12 to a widower
from Wisconsin but before that happened
we had lived in two other Amish
settlements there were old order Amish
in Western
Pennsylvania um he had from a previous
marriage he
had I believe nine boys or eight boys
and five girls something like that
there's like 23 of us with with all this
step
siblings and then we moved to Wisconsin
and I lived in two different older
ramish settlements in
Wisconsin in um 2004 when I was 19 I
escaped from the
abuse that I had
experienced and I ended up reporting
it and there were five people and my
immediate family that were arrested and
prosecuted for crimes they
committed can I ask you what kind of
stuff was going
on
um abuse of all types there was
religious trauma there was child sexual
abuse there was physical abuse there was
emotional
abuse
is that typical for the Amish
community you
know part of what happens when I talk
about why I escape is far too often
people respond with this well but you
could have just left on R Springer which
is a stereotype the idea that we get to
go out and experience the world and then
make a decision without any
repercussions that that's the Community
before you're 18 I
think um the thing is is that in the
five settlements I lived in specifically
we didn't even have room spring we said
we went with the young folks and we
didn't get to go out and live in the
world and experience the world and we
most certainly didn't have a choice to
be in the world and not practicing Amish
and not have repercussions for that
and so part of what happens is there's a
lot of stereotyping of Amish
people and stereotyping inherently when
you talk about stereotyping people if we
sit there and we say these people are
all good or they're all bad we're
inherently harming the very group of
people we're talking about
and I say this as somebody who
repeatedly hears reports
of people who are committing
suicide or perhaps that's not quite the
right way to say that maybe they're
they're dying from
suicide um
because of the lack of access to
appropriate
resources I
believe and
often rpr is a large part of what the
stereotyping plays into because people
think that we could have just
left and another part that is greatly
misunderstood is
that every Amish settlement inherently
has different
rules and those rules are in fact so um
diverse like in one
settlement they may be allowed
to have buggies with battery lights on
them and in a different old order Rish
settlement they may not be allowed to
have buggies with battery lights on them
and
and when we sit
there and we say the Amish inherently it
tends to
be that people don't understand that it
can be common it can be uncommon there
are certain things that are inherent so
for the settlements I lived in
specifically when we went with the Young
Folks at we would
say the ages varied it would be from
like 16 16 and a half 17 those were the
typical ages and what we were expected
to do was to find somebody to get
married
to we would go to the youth groups that
they called the singings on Sunday
evenings and then after that each
settlement had different practices on
how they allowed their youth to
date some settlements allowed bed
courtship um some settlements absolutely
did not allow bed courtship that wasn't
a thing that
was
even
acceptable and the other part is is
settlements don't necessarily affiliate
with each other so we can't just say the
Amish do this I can say that this was my
experience inside of these five Amish
settlements and we also can't say even
though experience crimes inside of each
one of those settlements I still can't
say that all Amish are bad people or
that all Amish commit
crimes
rather
it's
that Amish are people just like any
other group of people and some of them
commit
crimes and when
we have a culture of
silence and we have a
culture where we abour or or shun
[Music]
education
it tends
to
create
differences and how people understand
the world around them and also when we
consider the language differences I grew
up speaking Pennsylvania
Dutch or Dutch that we we just called it
Dutch really and I didn't learn how to
speak English until I went to school
when I was 6 years
old and so inherently many Amish people
most Amish people that I know
are English as a second language
speakers and how that affects people
when we go out into the dominant culture
and we try to assimilate into dominant
culture can vary
um depending on the degree of
insolar insularity that the settlement
had that they were a part of or even
depending
upon what their family practiced because
sometimes not just the settlement might
have different rules from their
neighboring settlement um because the
ministry gets together they might have
different Church districts and every
spring and every fall the ministry gets
together and they rewrite the rules for
that
settlement and inside of each Church
District it's the Ministries
responsibility to write that
rules the aning brief the ordinance
brief and then they take it to the
church and the church is supposed to
have a rote on it which is kind of like
a vote when I was baptized into the
church I was 17 years
old and I was told that anytime there is
a row
I'm not allowed to wrote against
whatever my stepfather wrote it as
because my vote had to support him to be
submissive to the authority
of the head of the
household but when you also
consider that in
2021 I Co wrote a a research study on
child sexual abuse within Amish menites
anabaptists and other religious
communities what we discovered without a
shadow of a doubt is child sexual abuse
does exist within Amish
settlements and
homes and then you consider one of the
questions that we ask the respon
was if you were taught that child sexual
abuse was a
sin what was it
called and some of the answers were
things like a moral
failure or
even a sin of lust or sex outside of
marriage a sin of
Darkness part of me has to ask
is this a thing where religious language
around
crimes affects how we think about it and
how we talk about
it and
maybe social
workers and people who come in contact
with Amish
people could benefit from understanding
better simply the language
differences or even understanding that
sometimes um using translators or
interpreters we need to use
people
and do our best to provide
services from
people who are qualified to be doing
that and I believe in Pennsylvania
specifically they are they are working
on um having an interpreter
program but I'm not quite sure where
that is right now but it is something
that is being worked
on and you reported your family members
what what was the uh aftermath of all
that oh
my well I was shunned in April
2004 I was
told by the English neighbor that I was
put in the bond the bond is like a
status and then they practice midom
which is the
shunning the aftermath of
that is
something that I don't quite know how to
put into good
words because
inherently
the
accusations made of me but also to sit
there and watch people show up in droves
for perpetrators of um child sexual
abuse I'd say that
um forever
Alters how you think about people in
general especially when those were your
your family members those were your
community
members those were the people that I
knew and to have it
all ripped
away I expected repercussions but I
didn't expect the church to put me in
the bond without following their own
rules the ministry was supposed to come
talk talk to
me but they
didn't and it's interesting because you
know when I was baptized I
promised that I wouldn't tell Church
business to
Outsiders and
um putting somebody in the bond is
church business
but it is very interesting that the
neighbor had to tell me that they put me
in the
bond and then it is
interesting how they wrote letters on
behalf of the
perpetrators and how they rallied around
them and how some of them even got up on
the witness and and testified for
them and how people that knew
me were being
questioned by law enforcement about my
whereabouts because
apparently the settlement that I escaped
from they couldn't
contact social services or DHS or you
know any of the people that would
investigate child sex
crimes
they couldn't contact
them but they could call local law
enforcement with blatant lies about me
when it was physically
impossible for me to be there doing what
they said I was
doing I ended up joining the
Army to get out of that state
because first I moved
when I escaped on February 16
2004 I wasn't too far from the
settlement I escaped
from but
then I moved and as the court cases went
on I moved again I moved further
away
and when my friends were being
questioned my co-workers were being
questioned
I asked law enforcement what can I do
because I'm not doing these things and I
don't know how to make it stop and they
said really the only thing I they know
is like to to move
away I moved again I moved 2 and 1 half
hours
away and then I moved
again and then I moved
again and I still wasn't any closer than
2 and 1/2 hours away And yet when I went
to the gas station to get gas one day
there's a whole vanload of Amish people
sitting right there and maybe they
didn't know that I was there I don't
know but at that point it
solidified the idea that I need to leave
the state I legally changed my name and
I joined the army and the Army took me
out of
Wisconsin the Army also
gave me different a different
perspective different set of values
introduced me to a whole bunch of
different
people and getting to know some of those
people taught me that
inherently groups of people around the
world have problems they have crimes
that are committed but how people handle
those problems matter if they have
crimes that are being
committed it matters how they handle it
and what they're doing about
it
and I also
learned that English as a second
language really does affect the way that
we
communicate
um one of my battle buddies actually
explained it to me when I was in medic
school
it was uh pretty interesting to hear and
get to know from so many people from so
many different walks and ways of life
because they taught me things about
myself and about where I came from that
I didn't even consider or think of until
they gave me the space to do so and that
inherently in and of itself is
beautiful and
then
after
that I ended
up
pregnant and I got chaptered out of the
army because I didn't have a family care
plan and it kind of felt like a betrayal
but in the same token I wasn't able to
do what I needed to do because both both
parents of this child were active duty
and so somebody had to get out and I did
what I had to
do and then um in 2008 I started going
to college for and I obtained my
associates degree in
2010 and I was still married to somebody
who was active duty and we went from
different military bases we ended up
moving overseas and I lived in Germany
for 5
years um we did
separate and get divorced while I lived
in
Germany
sometimes it's really
hard to get to a place where you can be
okay with who you are inside and
sometimes we do
things because we think it's expected of
us we feel like it's the right thing to
do according to everybody around
us those
values I found it beneficial to examine
where my values came from because
inherently when you can't stand yourself
and you feel like a part of you is from
such a terrible place from such a
terrible group of people if you are
demonizing an entire group of people and
specifically a group of people that is
your culture your heritage and you know
to be Amish is not just not just a
religion or a culture it's also a
business there's there's branding about
Amish and that is why it's so powerful
because there's a whole tourism industry
if you look at Lancaster County alone I
believe in 2022 it was estimated about
2.4 billion dollars in Amish
tourism well tourism maybe not all of it
was Amish but if you've ever been to
Lancaster County you know that a lot of
Tourism there comes from
Amish and there's a whole genetic
component
where there's an entire
database that
um
covers Amish menites hites and their
specific genetic disorders it even
delineates it by Amish or menonite or
huate
furthermore there's there's even
specific genetic disorders that um run
in my
family and um from from in breeding
it's they call it the founder effect in
research primarily it's because for
almost 400 years when we split from the
menites um because the menites didn't
practice shining right um we've we've
been marrying our second and third
cousins for almost sometimes fourth and
fifth and sixth cousins for almost 400
years and when that happens you get the
recessive traits becoming dominant and
that can result in genetic
disorders the type of Amish that I was
we rarely like we we didn't see people
joining us or even if they attempted to
join us you know they they would always
be of a lesser status because it was a
privilege to be born in the
church but anyways the point
is that is my culture that is my
Heritage it's in my me and I can't
outrun
that
and around
2018 when
um I had well actually let's let's back
up a little bit around
2014 I had been dating
somebody
and the relationship itself was fine
except for one thing I could not I could
not bring myself to
be intimate with this
person and that's when I had to really
examine the
internalized
homophobic ideas about myself because I
felt like it was fine for other people
to be gay or queer or trans or gender
fluid or all of these things but it
wasn't fine for me because if I was that
i' probably would go to
hell and one of the most freeing things
was having the space to be able to
process
that and understand what I believe and
that is
we are who we are and who we're
attracted to is just one faucet of who
we are it doesn't change who you are
inherently to be
queer it really
doesn't your values
remain it doesn't give you any less
value to be queer and to be openly
queer and so so I made a commitment that
I was going to live my life out loud and
in
color and that is part of
why this dress even though the dress
didn't happen until like
2020 because of things it takes time but
you're wearing an Amish dress omish
style dress but it's very
colorful well there's a few things
there's a few modific
just a few like I just want to point out
this stitching would have never been
allowed in myish settlements none of
them all five of them that would have
been straight to jail you would have
been
done for stitching this stitching oh no
that's way too
fancy the color absolutely
not um like for example like we had a
two finger rule so like my hair is not
properly displayed because like you know
I don't know if that was the church's
rule or my stepfather's rule but it was
two fingers and width of hair was
allowed to be displayed hair was
supposed to be parted straight and then
combed to the side if it went straight
back that was too
worldly this your covering so this is a
covering by the way and I just want to
say this because a lot of people don't
understand this is a cup it is not a
bonnet okay this this is supposed to be
tied and properly tied because if it's
not properly tied you know well that's
that's just not okay
either and um you know this this is
absolutely not
allowed having this embroidery stitching
on it not
allowed um this cape is a little too
narrow
the dress itself is a little too short
our dresses were supposed to be exactly
8 in from the floor in the last
settlement that I lived in the um
hemming here this is way too
wide and the color itself oh no
never but the type of fabric that this
is this is actually the type of fabric
that my workdresses were made from that
I would wear during the
week I got the right kind of fabric and
the shoes we would have never been
allowed to wear two-ton
shoes the heel is too high and this is a
little too fancy but the stockings right
here those are the right kind of
stockings they're they're they're the
right
kind because
sometimes reclaiming your heritage means
making things the way you wish you could
have made them when you were practicing
those beliefs and held those values as
the end all
be so for me it felt freeing to be able
to remake this into something that isn't
quite so doesn't feel quite so
oppressive and it doesn't make me feel
like I have to slump my shoulders and
and make myself small which is like you
know and when we were sitting in church
um we would be expected to sit like this
um to make yourself
small yep you would see rows of arish
women just sitting like
that sometimes they would sit like
this
but yes it was very much a reclaiming of
this is my Heritage and you can't take
that from me but also this part of it
where I know how to draft a dress
pattern based off of measurements for
this specific settlement like I can do
that but I can also make it something
that isn't oppressive to
me and there's a lot of Beauty in
that to be able to recreate
things that you can find joy in and that
you can find peace in and that you can
find a way forward and then you can look
at it and say well this is more me than
that ever
was and I think that gave me a certain
kind of piece with like the dress
itself oh and and this part these
sleeves are a little too
snug
so yeah do you talk with your family at
all my biological mother my oven she um
passed away I believe in
um I
tried to build a healthy relationship
with her for many
years and I don't know that I'm
really in a space
to speak about that publicly
because there's a
lot and she was one of the
people that was
prosecuted for failure to Aid a victim
and report a crime and she was one of
the people
who if you watch the doy series sins of
the Amish the prosecuting attorney reads
from the letter she wrote him about
me but
she she was a person who I'm very sure
had her own trauma
however when you have children you have
an obligation and responsibility to
them and I do think that people can do
better as Maya Angelo says people when
they know better they can do better and
sometimes people who know better or who
are are informed of better they were
they reject that and they choose to
continue down a pathway of um
destructive
Behavior towards people they Proclaim to
love other than
that
um 2018 was the last time I spoke
to my practicing any of my practicing
Amish
family but
ultimately I was also told never to come
back by someone I care deeply
about but I also think that's part of
the harm of shunning because shunning
inherently tears apart families shunning
demonizes
people and I kind of feel like going
back to the whole stereotyping and bias
thing when when you stereotype people
when you stereotype people who leave for
people who are not practicing you know
and you make them into you make it into
an Us Versus Them thing and then it
leads to bias and then inherently it
enables harm against those
people and you know the other thing is
say what kind of a choice is it really
to be baptized into the Hest Church
versus like going out into the world and
knowing that you're perhaps never going
to be treated like you you probably
aren't going to be invited to weddings
and you know you might not be um allowed
to attend funerals or you know you might
not be allowed to sit with the family at
the funeral because all of a sudden
you're this really bad
person and I don't know that it's
necessarily just because I left that I'm
this really bad person
it's potentially exacerbated
by the fact that I'm this bad person
because I reported abuse to Civil
Authorities who
prosecuted
and what leads me to that conclusion is
that you know other people who were also
shunned from that settlement they can
attend funerals that I'm asked to stay
away from they can attend funerals and
walk through and view the dead as is
customary for our culture uh um but I
was sent an escort of 12 men to tell me
I'm not allowed to walk through and view
my brother that passed away in 2004
because it's my fault that they went to
prison and that they can't be here for
his funeral so it's only fair that I'm
not allowed to view my brother that
passed
away
and the other thing is is that the
effects of shining itself can also vary
in different families like even from
settlement to family how they shun
people may
vary based on what they perceive is the
appropriate type of
shunning but then I think it's also
important to have Nuance here where
people can perhaps understand
that
this is what I
experience and other people may
experience it differently and it doesn't
mean that either of us or any of us are
wrong when we talk about our experiences
specifically but it does
mean that there are varied
experiences
and you know in conclusion I would say
you know you can take the you you can
you can get out of the Amish community
you can get out of the settlement but
you can't take the Amish out of the
person and the other thing that I would
say is that you
know there's the plain people's podcast
out there which tells stories about
plain people and that can be inherently
helpful to under for Outsiders to
understand what some of the differences
are and yet
similarities in a Baptists are not a
monolith just because you see plain
people doesn't mean that it's Amish
people
people can live a plain lifestyle and
dress plain and be
atheists and I would also
say that abuse happens within groups of
people around the world and I'd ask you
to ask
yourself where do you stand on the issue
of combating
abuse where do you stand on this issue
what action have you taken to prevent it
from
happening are you part of the problem or
part of the
solution Choose
Wisely you can't be
both those are some of the most profound
words that anybody has ever said to me
and I cannot disclose the person's name
but a person said this to me many many
many years ago go and and it really
struck me as being a profound way of
looking at like I am a person and I may
be only one person but where do I stand
on this and I think sitting with that
and sitting with the uncomfortableness
of perhaps everything that you thought
you knew was maybe just a little
bit too
broadly defined
off
of the
experiences that eliminated experiences
of the most marginalized people within
Amish
communities and maybe you could benefit
from learning more about the experiences
of the most marginalized within Amish
communities thank
you all right Mary thank you very
much